buenos días
el sonido no
vamos a empezar otra vez buenos días
mucho mejor vamos a despertarnos un
poquito que ya llevamos un buen rato
bueno porque estoy hoy aquí la verdad es
que hace un par de años tuve tuve una
epifanía si suena muy fuerte decirlo así
pero tuve net y fanny a estaba en una
avioneta que la que no nos podíamos
poner de pie a más de 3000 metros de
altura en australia estaba enganchado
con un tío a la espalda demasiado pegado
y de repente abre la puerta segura de la
avioneta nos subimos a un pequeño
escalón y saltamos al vacío soltamos en
paracaídas y yo estaba pensando en esa
epifanía que porque me preguntaba no
tienes miedo digo no si total no no veo
a dónde voy porque voy a tener miedo y
es curioso porque durante toda mi vida
el mensaje que he recibido por parte de
la sociedad es que como no ves a dónde
vas tenés que tener miedo por ser ciego
tienes que tener cuidado porque lo
cierto es que en un mundo en el que todo
el mundo ve es fácil que si cierras los
ojos piensas que quien no vea lo tiene
difícil
tiempo después recordaba esta epifanía
porque acaba de terminar un máster de
transformación digital en una de las
organizaciones más prestigiosas del
mundo había vuelto a estudiar psicología
que lo que siempre había querido estaba
en una persona maravillosa que mi pareja
perdía mi trabajo y decía cómo hemos
llegado hasta aquí
y es difícil pensar en todos los pasos y
es difícil pensarlo sobre todo en el
momento en el que te quedas ciego porque
yo hasta 28 años veía perfectamente pero
por una enfermedad que en la que me
dijeron que no podía hacer movimientos
bruscos cosa que no escuché cómo es
obvio pues un día corriendo por mi casa
me tumbé y cuando volví a abrir los ojos
a los cinco segundos ya no veía nada lo
cierto es que no sabes cuál será el día
que cambie tu vida no sabes cuál será el
gesto cotidiano que transforme tu vida
radicalmente hay muchas cosas que
hacemos en el día a día y pensamos que
cuando acaben estas 24 horas algunos
menos porque algunos duermen demasiado
volverá todo a ser igual al día
siguiente pero lo cierto es que nuestra
vida está en constante cambio yo tuve la
suerte de refugiarme la natación que al
fin y al cabo es una piscina 50 metros
dos paredes dos cocheras y ahí nadie
podía decirme ten cuidado pero aún así
lo hacían y durante 12 años fui
deportista olímpico paralímpico
tuve la oportunidad de ir a tres
olimpiadas ganar
medallas pero hasta los 19 años a pesar
de que ya había ido a mi primera
olimpiada pensaba que ser ciego era una
grandísima injusticia que por alguna
razón yo no tenía los mismos derechos
que los demás porque claro si no puedes
llegar igual porque eres ciego no puedes
tener los mismos amigos porque eres
ciego no puedes mejorar en la natación o
en cualquier otra historia o incluso
aprender en la universidad igual porque
eres ciego y lo cierto es que cuando ya
interioricé ese mensaje y me lo creí a
los 19 años entre una crisis muy
profunda tan profunda que literalmente
no le veía salida toqué fondo y ahí fue
cuando llegó un momento por otras
referencias que no me dará tiempo
contaros llegó un momento en que
constate que a pesar de entrenar ojito
con el flash sé que me vas a dejar más
ciego a pesar de entrenar 7 horas
diarias seis días a la semana más de
2500 kilómetros al año lo único que no
estaba entrenando era mi mente y cuando
no entrenas tu mente no entrenas tus
emociones da igual lo que hagas tus
resultados siguen siendo escasos y ahí
fue cuando empecé a hacer la búsqueda
qué hacemos todos en google de cómo
entrenar mi mente y eso me llevó a
empezar a marcar mis objetivos me llevó
a aprender una serie de técnicas me
llevó a empezar a cambiar mis emociones
y mi lenguaje pero sobre todo me llevó a
que en menos de dos años pasé de ser un
finalista a batir dos récords del mundo
y dos de europa y ganar cuatro oros en
las olimpiadas de pekín 2008 claro al
volver de pekín
como os podéis imaginar fue cuando
empecé a dar conferencias a trabajar
como coach en equipos empresariales
deportivos en colegios y luego
posteriormente en un afán de seguir
probando que podías hacer más cosas
hicimos el ironman varias maratones
entre ellas la de nueva york- y cruzamos
el estrecho de gibraltar que por cierto
unas condiciones malísimas
pero
es relevante todo esto es relevante para
vosotros es importante que yo haya hecho
unas cosas u otras
realmente no pero todos absolutamente
todos los que estamos en esta sala y los
que nos ven todos afrontamos algún tipo
de adversidad quizás no la ceguera
quizás no sea una enfermedad mental
quizás no te quedes sin una pierna pero
todos tenemos una adversidad y cuando
tenemos una diversidad en el mundo en el
que vivimos nos dicen que nos tenemos
que centrar simplemente en bueno tubo
olvídate intentar ser feliz y esperas a
que otros te ayuden pero sabéis que mi
vida me ha enseñado y las miles de
personas con las que he tenido la
oportunidad me ha enseñado que hay tres
claves imprescindibles para afrontar la
adversidad y la primera es no esperar a
que el mundo venga a salvarte no esperar
porque si tú te quedas sentado esperando
a que los demás cambien el mundo y la de
cv en a ti es muy poco probable que
consigas que las cosas si esperas a que
los demás vengan a arreglar tu vida es
muy poco probable que salgas de dónde
estás porque todo el mundo dice bueno
quédate ahí sentado venga que te llevo
tranqui
pero si no pueden contar su buena
voluntad la segunda es dejar de evitar
dejar de evitar afrontar las cosas y
afrontar aquellas circunstancias que
sean que representen una dificultad para
nosotros y empezar a actuar no tanto de
pensar imaginar y poner los propósitos
de año nuevo ni visualizar aquello de
ahí me encantaría
no actuar actuar porque es lo único
concreto que tenemos y la tercera y para
mí una de las más importantes
es confiar
confiar en nosotros mismos y confiar en
algunas personas que nos rodean porque
cuando aceptas los mensajes de la
sociedad generalmente todos te van a
decir que tú no puedes hacer algo por
alguna razón sea la que sea pero la
realidad
y es una realidad fundamental es que la
mayor discapacidad que tenemos no es la
ceguera no es una discapacidad física no
es una discapacidad mental
la mayor discapacidad que todos tenemos
es no confiar en nosotros mismos muchas
gracias y a confiar
[Aplausos]